And Esther is a, I mean, I'm going to say this.
I like to give people props where they deserve it. You, I,
I'm going to be honest with you.
There is been no one like you in the stand-up comedy world.
I don't know if that's a good thing, but,
but there has been no one like you in the 20 years that I've been doing.
You know what, even from an outsider's perspective, you have a very,
very specific and particular voice and look and overall
image compared to anyone else. And I think that's, you know,
such a great advantage for you just cause you're odd. You're all, you're
like Jeffrey Dahmer. You're not Jeffrey.
You're more like, no, you're like.
Andrew Cunanan. He's half Filipino.
You know, like back in the day when they starting the circus.
Yeah. [inaudible].
But I also want to say that you're young and you know why also I love you is
that we're, you're very neurotic. Like I am, you get diarrhea all the time.
Her boyfriend does. Yeah.
Oh my God. Don't say that. I'm the opposite. I get constipated. Yeah.
Oh really? Yeah. Cause he told me once your boyfriend, I don't care.
He told me what's a, he takes, um, what's that 80 before meals just in case.
It makes me imagine taking him on every meal.
And just in case you're going to get diarrhea. It's living life in a prison.
No he's being safe.
It's like putting a cork in it so that it never condoms.
But like he should address what is the problem? Really IBS.
If it just goes through him each time, speaking of what is the problem,
Khalilah, maybe you should come over. Maybe I should ask her.
Our relationship is very strange.
Khalilah is a nurse. It's.
Strictly a nurse patient relationship. If you go through the whole,
the history of our text messages,
it's just a bunch of pictures of Esther's rashes. The inside of her mouth.
Like her tonsils, her CT scan.
I stopped watching photos. I mean, it's like, I gotta go. I don't wanna,
I don't, I don't want to deal with it. Yeah.
Well text me from New Zealand. I think I'm dying. What do I have? God
rashes. Do you get, I get all sorts of rashes. I, well,
when I was in New Zealand, I had a swollen lymph node.
Carlisle has helped me so much. Like I,
I don't even know where to start, but there's so many, like,
she's just so good and the liable, but I keep coming back,
like knowing her as me and my life significantly better. Oh, that's really nice.
You're you're a touch hypochondriacal but I think, you know that I do. I do.
And I feel like I'm very aware when I'm texting you. Like, I'm like,
I know this is crazy. Yeah. Hopefully I say that. And when I,
when I was switching over phones and I was like, Hey, like, sorry,
I didn't reply back your phone. My phone's broken. She was like, okay,
make sure you have a phone soon, a new phone soon.
Like it was a legit concern for her just in case like a new rash, you know,
sprouts up.